well thanks for the introduction I'm now
thoroughly intimidated or the list of
luminaries and scientists and brilliant
folks in the room so I'm just an energy
guy but I'll do my best thanks again for
having me here tonight I think this is
your fourth annual conference I'm sure
there'll be many more because these
issues aren't going away anytime soon
it's my pleasure to participate in the
event that's important I'm also
encouraged that you're you want to
address the obvious nexus of water
energy and climate you know I'm proud to
be in a company that also recognizes
that Nexus you know our called alveoli
environment for a reason environmental
company we work at that a focal point
and again proud to do it so why are we
all in this room I think you know
there's a recognition growing its exists
but it's growing you know the community
of people that get it recommended these
fundamental elements of life here on
earth of water energy and climate are
beginning to impact the everyday life of
even the most privileged among us that's
us the spoiled people I dare say no one
doubts that it's going to affect has the
potential to affect the security and
prosperity of our children I say that
because I usually speak to older crowds
but with some of the younger folks here
you will have children and you'll worry
about them too like I worry about mine
and it's also a fact that for millions
of people today never mind the future
these issues posed a increasing
challenge they pose real life challenges
and those will only get worse unless we
do something about it so and moving
forward and I'm sure you guys will talk
about this tomorrow and going forward
you know in the past they think a lot
has been focused on mitigation and now
there's more people talking about
adaptation and its really got to be both
there's not going to be any silver
bullets we are going to have climate
impacts we are going to challenge our
water supplies we are going to stretch
our energy supplies the question becomes
we need to mitigate and adapt as we move
forward so that we cause the least harm
ultimately
you know the answers will come from a
broad spectrum it'll be new technologies
it'll be better use of existing
technologies it'll be evolutionary and
maybe revolutionary change in consumer
behaviors we hope they'll be new science
there'll be good policy I say good i
think the hopes are great is too much to
ask but we'll hope for good policy so
with that I don't me just before I move
on just a simple image and I was kind of
preparing for this and I just thought to
go i was looking at satellite images and
you take a satellite image of the global
you know the indian subcontinent and you
do on a day and you're due on at night
so in the day what do you see you look
down on the Himalayas and you see white
ok ice and snow water storage you see
just south of the himalayas green ok you
know the the rains also the off flow of
dams ok now you look to the west to the
stands and you see brown as if that
region didn't have more to fight over
okay now you're just overlay and then
you flip to the nighttime view and you
see that what 50 years ago was doc is
now lit up right so between water and
energy and climate in places like that
which are critically important you know
it's part of the issue is going to be
will think about our own turf but it's
really a global issue and we're all into
tied now it's just it's it's a
compelling issue we need to deal with so
now just for a bit of expectation
management I don't have the answers so
I'll try to you know I'm going to hit
you with some some facts that highlight
some of the the nexus of these issues
I've got you right where I want you your
captive you've eaten you've had copious
amounts of wine so you're all kind of
happy right now so this is good I'll try
not to put you to sleep as well alright
so i'll start with water we'll just that
with water before we go on from there a
couple of statements you know 120
years ago 1 300 years ago you know
National Geographic you know the
statement that you here now all the
water that will ever be is right now so
finite resource right and then you get
the old Benjamin Franklin founding
father wisdom when the well is dry we
know the worth of water right so anyway
so I'll start off with that so what
makes up the Earth's water resource
ninety-seven percent of the Earth's
water is ocean largely unusable to us at
least in a economical way at this point
two percent frozen in ice caps glaciers
and snow I'll come back to that when we
talk about climate another small portion
exists in Saltillo menses lakes soil
moisture the atmosphere which leaves one
percent left for us to use for domestic
use ok that's the small portion of
Earth's supply of water usable water one
percent zine underground reservoirs
groundwater another small amount in
lakes surface water and the smallest
amount is in rivers and oh by the way
that point zero zero zero one or one
ten-thousandth of percent of the usable
water that's in rivers is where we
obtained most of our water okay so note
to file power plants drink heavily from
rivers so we'll come back to that it's
the supply is unevenly distributed
across the earth service and for example
in Malaysia a hundred people share each
million cubic meters of water ok so in
Malaysia 100 people shared in India 350
people share in Israel 4000 people share
it okay so it's not distributed in any
type of homogenous fair economic
whatever you want to call it the globe
knows no boundaries right it's just the
planet Earth by 2050 the world's
population is you know supposed to be at
nine billion up from seven and you know
according to the United Nations that
water use to continue
to expand at more than 2x the rate of
population growth so we're going to go
from seven to nine billion and water use
grows twice as fast you know the
industrialization of the world the
creation of middle classes classes all
over the world that we've seen the
miracle of vino and China and India it's
a great thing for people to come out of
poverty and join the middle class they
also become consumers at a much higher
level so something to be dealt with you
know speaking of China the water table
under Beijing is sinking by six feet a
year I have any of you guys been to
Beijing lately as if they didn't have
enough problems with the environment huh
you know the the coal plants are an
issue the air is tough to breathe and
the water table is sinking six feet a
year under Beijing okay the vast a gala
aquifer which runs through eight states
basically runs from Texas up to the
Dakotas which is a huge resource for a
water scarce area as dropping three feet
of year okay and then i'll come back to
fracking but you know gas exploration is
going to tax that as well so there's
copious amounts of water used for in
those regions and in place where we're
already scarcity so lots of challenges
so who are the culprits on the
waterfront irrigation okay top culprit
seventeen percent of the world's crops
are grown through irrigation yet they
produce thirty-three percent of the
world's food so that's why we do it okay
irrigated land is two and a half times
as productive as non irrigated land it's
it's not going to end anytime soon
unfortunately the majority of the water
never reaches the crops and I'm generous
saying majority so that would mean fifty
percent reaches the crops it's worse
than that eighty-five percent of the
water consumed in the u.s. is through
irrigation okay
and half of the world's irrigation is in
three countries take a wild guess US
China India okay yet irrigation is
facing a competitive challenge for
low-cost high-quality water which Segway
is a nice segue into my next point so
why as water so cheap is it priced right
and i think it is obviously agree i'm
talking to experts here so you know i'm
not surprising many people in the room
but from an industrial side from the you
know the guy who's trying to run power
plants and feed district energy systems
water prices vary drastically and
fundamentally the prices do not reflect
the all-in cost of water they don't you
know the energy business if you look at
the cost of an electron has done a you
know i'll call it much better job at
pricing in the cost of energy i'm an
energy guy my water colleagues might
debate this with me but i think they
generally agree so this direct cost is a
financial cost building wastewater
treatment plants pumping stations pipes
there's environmental costs waste
generated from water processing
degradation of return streams fertilizer
you know runoff from irrigation and in
this resource cost what is the cost when
you deplete a resource ok you can price
the damn can you price the drought
harder to do particularly when it's on
the other side of a border of your enemy
okay so pricing isn't is a challenge
that's got to be solved water has got to
be priced at a level that will drive
consumption that will drive decision
making just you know for example in the
developed world germany compared to the
u.s. four times the cost of water
domestic water in germany is us and it's
not because fundamentally their
processes are less efficient because
they priced it that way you know the
european since i work for a french
company and i work with my European
colleagues frequently there there's
places where we
ahead of them there's places where
they've been way ahead of us from a
policy and incentive perspective you can
argue that you know you can argue both
sides of the fence and sentence good are
they bad do they create bad behaviors
but they certainly have made some
efforts in particular nasarah pricing
water differently than we have there's
widespread subsidies farming what a
shock another farming subsidy thought I
knew of every farming subsidy there was
but I just then realized after doing you
know some some research here that in
fact weeds a heavy subsidy because of
the water huge discounts on the water
used for irrigation you know again back
to our satellite view of this Indian
subcontinent so basically China and
Nepal on the ice the water storage in
the owns the water and the dams and
everybody else waits in line so it's
it's an interesting concept of
ultimately this this pricing factor who
controls the resource how will it be
distributed is interesting and demand
side management strategies with and
without pricing evidence shows and I
think there was a read of paper from a
professor Olmstead from yield actually
and I was a Yale Harvard collaboration
are actually I'm from Boston so I should
say a harvard yale collaboration and
they talked about the pricing elasticity
of of water in other words or the lack
thereof and you know for non economist
speak that means you make the price
higher and people will use just as much
i don't buy it and their study says they
don't buy it either there's evidence
that you know there is direct
correlation between pricing of water and
its use you know great examples we were
talking at the table tonight about you
know just consumer behaviors and
competition water bills went up in my
town substantially and then my neighbor
had to let me know you know he basically
and of course i'm a water hog i've got
sprinklers on my lawn my community is
all green grass
guilt-ridden but my neighbor told me how
much he had tweaked down his sprinklers
they got his bill cut by like forty
percent I'll be damned if he was going
to beat me okay so I without did tuning
my sprinklers watching every patch of
the grass getting it right down
tolerating a few brown spots you know so
that there is I mean pricing does matter
you know even in a microcosm like that I
could tell you we own we own and operate
district energy systems across the u.s.
for the largest portfolio plants in the
US and on average in cities where the
number want to do to customers so again
energy is water intensive okay and I'll
come back to that but we're also
experiencing double-digit increases in
water pricing routinely in many cities
trust me all of my managers have in
their objectives ways to squeeze down
water use pricing matters you know in as
I think about it particularly for in
city generators which tend to be smaller
generators there there there they don't
necessarily benefit from a pricing
support on the electricity side because
they're in city depends which market you
sit in but for them the percentage of
their non fuel costs that are being
chewed up by water continues to grow and
grow and grow and it becomes a
competitive issue for in city generators
you know bottom line the politics of
raising water prices and eliminating
subsidies are difficult it comes down a
lot of it is politics you know you talk
about the concept of water rights what
does that mean every earthling right has
a basic right to a quantity of water and
I like to say earthling I don't like
human human that I stop comparing myself
to other you know we just all we're all
creatures in the earth so I like
earthling so every earthling should have
a right to certain amount of water right
to survive what happens when you go
above that that in
that in a legal right to be able to get
a glass of water should you pay more for
it is it a luxury why don't we treat it
like a luxury we don't bottom line so I
mean it's got to happen you know
something else struck me as funny i was
reading this I earlier my in my leading
I call these basic elements you know
water energy and and climate and didn't
a great guy reference this like a couple
of two thousand years ago wasn't it
water fire air and what was the other
one I guess earth earth right aren't we
still talking about those water fire and
air water energy climate so interesting
jump ahead a few thousand years in time
so moving to the macroeconomic risks
look go to the big picture the World
Economic Forum a World Economic Forum
recently raided the next get dex next
Wow okay then next decades 50 global
risks in five different sectors so risk
typical risk probability versus
consequence water supply crisis rated
number one or two depending on how you
kind of looked at the numbers one or two
in the next decade and it had great
company at the top okay major systemic
financial failures that can't happen
right chronic fiscal imbalances so to
sit with my son I was reading through
this with by 14 year old he says dad did
they be in Washington they say that I
had to say no that was number six that
was chronic failure of nation states to
deal with global issues so anyway so it
had great company but it's up there and
you know you have a world forum to look
at critical issues and there's this
pretty strong sense that it's going to
happen and it's going to happen soon my
follow-on after I son listened in on
this and I walked we're talking through
all these risks my wife chimed in and
said oh thank you for the nice bedtime
story for William is it basically you
know the sword of Damocles over our head
so how big is it and what can be done my
colleague Lorant goosed which so many
people know here he's a CEO of our water
business in the Americas recently
presented on the subject and we
commissioned a study veolia commission
to study with the Food Policy Research
Institute so compared to today by 2050
the number of people living in water
scarce areas will increase by ninety
percent okay so part of it is is driven
by demand scarcity the other part is
just where are people moving to where is
the concentration of humans they'll be
half there'll be five billion people by
2050 living in water scarce regions by
2050 the GDP produced in water scarce
areas increased by five hundred and
twenty percent and again you look at it
and fundamentally it's it's places like
India and China at sixty three trillion
dollars worth of GDP that will shift
into water scarce regions part of what
this growing blue initiative is which
water interests are looking at around
the world is to trying to figure out
sustainable approaches to the growing
blue growing with with the water in mind
and there's many existing the tools are
there you know so part of the study was
to figure out okay so that's the future
not five hundred and twenty percent
increase shifting GDP to water ski areas
what can we do about it through existing
technologies known policies known
protocols we could de-risked 17 trillion
dollars worth of that pretty easily
that's the size of the US economy okay
so I mean part of part of what you guys
will be figuring out not me I'll have my
little piece of it but you guys will be
the the type of think tanks that figure
this out is to not only figure out the
new technology in the new policies what
do we already have what do we already
have what you'd be using so now let's
move on we'll add energy to the water
mix water is energy intensive itself so
the cycle to extract transport treat
distribute is very energy intensive
energy costs can represent 75% of the
processing and distribution costs of
municipal water so seventy-five percent
of the cost of water is chewed up by the
energy to move it around many cities
between thirty and fifty percent of
their entire municipal budget is chewed
up by the energy to move water around or
to treat water okay so fifty percent of
municipal budgets are just on the energy
piece of water it too few cities have
really sought ways to reduce this
expense and for not good reasons I mean
if you look at I know since we have
steam districts in many urban centers in
the US you know so you talk in Boston I
talked with the folks in New York Philly
Baltimore st. Louis Kansas City you get
on the list Chicago one of the biggest
problems for our districts is water
leaks spilling over onto our onto our
energy infrastructure the infrastructure
is crumbling the staffs are it's
undemanding credible and it's a lot of
this is low-hanging fruit I don't know
about if there's any other business
folks in the room what I hear
low-hanging fruit I'm hatching
salivating right now is thinking about
it you know I mean the amount of money
thats hanging out there that these
municipalities with help could go in and
find because they're not necessarily
tooled up to find it is extraordinary we
you know we've started a model jump to
the energy industry four-minute escos
everybody know what s cozaar anybody
know what s kazar okay basically ESCOs
are companies that go in and then say
we'll look at your office tower will
look at your campus your hospital campus
your university campus we will do
upgrades to your equipment will change
out your lights will change out your
coolers will invest that capital and
then when you when you show savings we
get a cut that's how a Tesco works so
they come in put their money in a table
and you share the cut on the savings
there's no west coast they met they may
be soon but water has been treated
differently where we focused a lot of
time and efforts on megawatts right
which is reducing watts
having spent many on mega drops okay
there just hasn't been much it doesn't
have the same level of penetration from
industry to get in there and help out
the municipality so that needs to come
we just actually shameless plug we we
just signed a contract with New York
City just to do that well where our
water division will go in work with the
city of New York we're already doing it
we're identifying improvements will
drive through do those improvements and
then get a cut of the savings so it
makes sense so and then the final thing
I want to talk about here when we talk
about nexus before I move on to energy
is that it's fine to talk about the the
nexus of water and energy particularly
before we get to climate but what we run
into a lot in industry is people don't
buy things that way so in other words
when I go to talk to a hospital or a
town or a city and I talked to the
procurement people and we say hey look
where this great company we do water we
do waste we do energy system stop
talking energy that's all I want to talk
about the other guy does water you see
that all the time there's really just
not a cohesive strategy on the
procurement side of many organizations
to figure out how do i link these things
do I get a better bang for a buck if I
start linking these things up so we need
to figure that out I mean that's another
kind of a process policy thing that an
companies only sell the way customers by
I've seen too many times when we try to
convince customers and how smart we are
and we have the better solution and then
go and buy from the other guy who sells
them what they want so the procurement
side of how we look at water and energy
needs to improve so moving on to energy
the fundamentals of bulk electricity
production have changed little in 50
years any light bulbs that just finally
starting to change and that was how long
ago you know now oh by the way I better
get a big hand raised here how many
people of LED lights in their house here
okay and this crowd is as good as it
gets right okay so eighty-nine percent
of electricity
generated from hydroelectric steam and
steam and water turbine cycles that
hasn't changed in more than 50 years
okay we're finally now you see more of
combined cycle gas plants you hear what
that means is a gas turbine on the front
end a steam turbine on the back end
there's still water intensive on average
it takes about two gallons of water per
kilowatt hour to generate electricity
okay and interestingly enough it's about
Brooke for a conventional power plant
it's about a half a gallon for
hydroelectric plant to about 18 gallons
because of the evaporation when you look
at what the evaporative effect of the
bodies of water that are created by the
dams and then you look at the output on
the on this on the sluice ways and you
look at the fall out it's a very high
evaporation rate so it's kind of an
interesting fact but about two gallons
per KW power generation uses forty-one
percent of the total domestic and
commercial consumption I'm sorry to kill
you with so many numbers here but again
we're just trying to give you some scale
ideas so almost half of the water used
in the US is chewed up by power plants
that's for domestic consumption that's
irrigation out remember we already said
irrigation is the big culprit but after
irrigation is carved out that's domestic
use half of that is used up by power
plants it's four percent of the total
consumption even when you look at
irrigation fifty-four percent of the
total consumption including irrigation
everything is withdrawn by power plants
what does that mean that means that i
said earlier power plants drink a lot
from rivers and oceans and they need to
cool they have steam turbines so they
you burn your fossil fuel or for that
matter you have nuclear fission and you
ultimately make steam with that stuff so
you convert the energy to make steam you
run it through a turban you have to get
that steam back so that it's a cycle
otherwise the amount of water use would
be outrageous so it's a closed cycle but
to cool that steam you need more water
so you take water out of a river water
out of the ocean or use a cooling tower
so
forward the tape to climate so
fifty-four percent of the watery
withdrawn is from power plants you know
what happens when river levels get low
power plants have to dear a one river
water temperatures get high enough the
EPA throws you out they shut your plant
down so this is going to be an
interesting challenge and I'll give you
an example of it in a bit but where
climate will then roll in on top of
water use even if it's returned you know
the resource is going to be challenged
and what's it going to do to the power
gen sector it's going to be very
interesting and as we see you know I
mean let me roll there right now so you
have this challenge also where there's
environmental impact from that thermal
plume so to cool all that steam if
you're an ocean plant or a river plant
you take cold water in and put hot water
back out the fish lobby don't generally
like that they die and you've heard
enough about fishery issues to know that
that's a sensitive subject that's now
another was an externality but now it's
working its way in so what does bit more
and more of is we're shifting from
withdrawal role close a sense simple
cycle once through cycle power plants to
plants with big nuclear ask cooling
towers okay because they heat the air
instead of heating the bodies of water
well guess what they do they use a lot
more water so actually the trade-off
we're making for another environmental
reason which is the marine biota marine
deaths caused by thermal flumes is going
to cause us to use a lot more water I'll
give you an example another thing that
you know about cooling we're addicted to
air conditioning in the US right Tyra
most clothings are going into summer at
65 degrees my French colleagues you know
drives them crazy because they don't do
air conditioned you're up just Emily
doesn't do a lot of it the Middle East
is trying to catch up with us oh by the
way they building cooling plants like
they're going out of style but for
example we have a plant in Boston
its affiliated with Harvard Medical
School and all the teaching hospital so
over the longwood medical area Boston so
it's a sizable cooling water plant
40,000 tons of cool languages how its
measured and it just heats those five
hospitals I'm cools us five hospitals
it's evaporates about a million and a
half gallons a day of water up the
cooling towers and at the small plant
you know compared to one of these big
hyperbolic towers for you know big coal
plant big new plant whatever and every
roof from an air-conditioning
perspective you know you go up on the
towers when you're in the towers of New
York you look down on the roofs what do
you say cooling towers everywhere our
consumption of water related to air
conditioning is is continuing to grow
and that grows round the world Europe
didn't do it because their buildings are
old enough Middle East is new and guess
what China is getting too like air
conditioning to and India will probably
like it as well because it's available
so that's going to be another new hole
demand perspective on water use and in
energies because making cold air is is
also very energy intensive situation you
know so I've described some of the you
know the issues in the u.s. it's worse
than water ski areas you know for
example India again you take India I
keep coming back to that a recent report
by the World Resources Institute notes
that you know the eighty percent of
India's future power plants will be
located in water scarce or water
stressed areas you know developing
countries have the right to grow and
whether it's a right or not they're
going to do it what's going to happen
the stress that it induces will be will
be I guess we'll find out what it would
be that's what that's the only way to
look at that
high electricity costs in also prohibits
the feasibility of desalination plants
we all like to look at the oceans and
say hey tons of water but the cost of D
cell is still very high there's some
emerging technologies but it's still at
the end of the day very energy intensive
and oh by the way you create the water
on the coasts you still get to get the
water inland so again just more energy
intensive infrastructure deep deep
aquifer production long distance
pipelines inter-basin transfer the hole
that the cost of electricity the cost of
energy to move that water may be
prohibitive to some of those
technologies just won't be
cost-effective so what's what's part of
the what can be part of the story on
this energy front we talked about
combining Bauer so you look at the
energy industry in 50 years has gone
from electricity generation has gone
from thirty percent efficient to fifty
percent 50 years so it's not bad right
basically one technology combined cycle
gas turbine plant gas turbine plants yet
we have this other technology called
combined heat and power okay used to be
called koh gen now it's combined heat
and power to change the name it's the
same concept there you burn a fuel you
make electricity by turning a turban for
example like a gas turbine and then
instead of having the hot gases that
come out of the back end of the term and
go up a stack you actually use those to
heat cities heat buildings it's
eighty-five percent efficient so I'll
tell you the tale of Denmark for a
minute ok so Denmark decided back in the
90s that they were on an unsustainable
trajectory okay they were
energy-dependent totally
energy-dependent they thought it would
affect their GDP substantially when they
looked at the basically the gas problems
of the world so they decided to go a
different route they said you know what
combined heat and power is going to be a
big part of our story and now
ninety-eight percent of the buildings in
Copenhagen are signed up to a district
energy system
that's fed by a combined heat and power
plant 60 almost seventy percent of every
structure in Denmark is attached to a
combined heat and power plant those are
eighty-five percent efficient and its
technology has been around an awful long
time since 1990 their greenhouse gas
profile has gone down fifteen percent
while their GDP went up forty percent so
you don't have to pay on both ends you
can have it both ways with some existing
technologies you know in the US for
example we invented district energy so
all these big urban piping networks that
were built by the utilities where the
first ones were built in the US all your
major cities Boston as I said Boston New
York Philly Baltimore you name it
they're all sitting there but what has
changed a lot since the day is that a
lot of these are fed by big combined
heat and power plants so in each one of
those cities I just named more than more
than half of the energy that heats those
downtown's is otherwise would have gone
up a cooling tower or into a river other
than the fact for combining power but
how many of you people knew that and we
don't even we're going to talk about it
it's an old technology that can take
huge bites out of carbon emissions so
why aren't we doing it are there any of
utility executives in the room other
than me can you turn the tape off at
this point now I mean the main barriers
it would weigh are in the way or its
utility reform I mean you have the
regulated pipes and wires utilities that
i'll talk a deregulated environments so
where most of our people live and where
most of our energy gets produced they
sold off they get forced to sell off the
power plants and they were left with
transmission and distribution what so
what where do you use combined eatin
power you don't use it out in every
household yet so you look for energy
dense fields where there's lots of
energy in a compact compact area
hospitals universities office towers
industrial sites how do you think the
utilities want to least lose so that so
the barriers that are still in place are
most of these utility utilities when the
deal was done
when they were forced to sell off their
power plants the quid pro quo was they
got exclusive franchise rights to run
wires and streets so as you you want
your hospital your you're a college you
want to put in a combined heat and power
plant you want to take advantage of this
you know from an economic perspective
social responsibility Adi Adi you can't
connect your campus unless you don't
have to cross the street good luck and
these battles have gone on for years I
mean I interesting one with
harvardharvard is trying to expand a
part of the campus from cambridge / unto
the Boston side and they wanted to
basically build a micro grid plop
cogen's in their smart buildings you
know the whole the whole deal and the
local utility said that's not going to
work that's all right that's a franchise
rights and what they in the bottom line
is the economics of combined heat and
power part of it is you're more
efficient so you burn less fuel the
other part is you're making your own
electricity you don't have to buy it
from the utility so you don't have to
pay transmission and distribution charge
that's the big economic turning point
particularly as gas prices have gone
down it costs more for T&D than it does
for the end for the electrons okay
generally in most locations so if you
have to use the utilities wires guess
what you still gotta pay T&D I ran the
unreg the unregulated businesses of a
utility and it was this that these
separate businesses combined heat and
power district energy so I kind of know
that the deal from their side of the
table and it's it's a it's a it's a fear
of basically Swiss cheesing their their
prime customers and that's got to end I
mean it's got to end we've got to find
ways to do that and and it's tough as a
utility executive because they've got
you know they want to be socially
responsible now so I've shareholders you
know and and there's nothing in in the
stock that talks about particularly next
quarter stock that talks about
greenhouse gas water use energy
efficiency it's just not there yet it's
coming but it's been slow so this this
whole you know the whole combined heat
and power stories is really
it's a sad story it should be much more
ubiquitous and we do our best we try to
promote it which will take to the next
next part of what I want to talk about
so would any energy discussion be full
without talking about fracking right
okay natural gas in the u.s. is an
absolute game changer okay it's turning
everything on its ear combined heat and
power included so and I don't know where
you guys sit on the science I mean it's
all over the place but generally the
science that I've read maybe I'm biased
is that it's telling me that all those
molecules are coming out of the ground
one way or another we'll figure out the
water issues maybe it'll be dry fracking
instead of wet fracking we'll figure out
the methane leakage issue but they're
coming out of the ground so if they're
coming out of the ground at the price
points that everybody sees because we're
sitting on an ocean of gas in the u.s.
it's huge and we just find out more and
more reserves every time we stick a you
know a drill in the ground somewhere
else we're either going to smother out
some of these other opportunities all
we're going to feel it figure out how to
deal with them with with policy so it's
going to be a challenge you know I guess
it's also worthy of note that part of
the fracking i mentioned dry fracking
you know for example a 2007 study in the
fort worth texas area dry already seven
to thirteen percent of the area
groundwater would be consumed to
liberate the local shale gas reserves
that's a big chunk so again i mean is
this compelling reasons for the gas to
come out of the ground you know this
huge we see it right now this huge
industrial ship the production to the US
right now you hear about some of the new
chemical plants being built some of the
new fertilizer plants being built but
you also what you don't hear is that
where there's already plants where they
had idled production they're ramping
that production up there's a lot of
reasons why it's good for us to have gas
in the US you know you call it energy
security economic benefit carbon
reduction because the coal plants are
shutting down they're dead there's a lot
of good reasons but we still need to
figure out part of the picture and we
have one
plant left and it's basically got three
years of life left in it we've got our
gas conversion plan set up but we were
doing coal gas price swapping last
summer just purely on existing economics
gas is cheaper than coal so it's it's
real so as before I flop over to climate
couple of tidbits and hopefully you know
I I won't go on too much longer hope I'm
not losing you here but again while
we're talking about fracking and water
and energy we might as well talk a
little bit about Canadian tar sands
right got to talk about them half a
barrel of water per barrel of oil
produced okay let's leave out the energy
part we'll just talk about the water
part of it you know as the government
has tried to figure out because the data
is not good which all I'm going to end
on some of that that's part of my
discussion point the government's trying
to figure out what really are all the
costs associated with the dis Texas in
2007 Sandia National Labs study
indicates that end-to-end energy
production accounts for twenty five
percent of all consumption of water so
early I was saying it was four percent
because that's what the numbers tell you
right now when you really look at
because that doesn't include mining that
doesn't include all the real end and it
probably jumps up closer to twenty five
percent of our water is used for energy
production so inextricably linked so
moving on to climate now to add to this
noxious brew altered global hydrological
cycles know that mean that means there
is that our water stress today will face
even greater impacts in the future
uncertainty of a future weather patents
impacts decades long life cycle of
planned infrastructure this is an
interesting point to me so we already
know that municipalities a strain that
infrastructure investment is difficult
to do and then now we come to find out
that because we really don't understand
the climate way it may have put the
stuff in the wrong place or that we
might have to deal with warmer summers
and
you know increased storm sighs so are we
really even designing and building and
maintaining our infrastructure correctly
I know there's a lot of focus in in some
of the Northeast cities on sea level
rise I know no one's house is getting
inundated but many of our cities their
critical infrastructure is already
getting licked by tidal waters
underground and it won't take much to
make it a lot or so a lot more cities
are getting interested in that so what
if this is I'm just going to run through
these quickly because i know i've been
talking probably longer than I should
but so what if is predicted we talk
about climate right tons of science out
there this red tie really it's not
political affiliation it was for the Red
Sox but you know both sides of the aisle
you know the crazy stuff goes around but
what if it's true I mean what if it is
increased temperatures increase
evaporation rates and decrease water
availability decrease precipitation for
low and mid latitudes increased drought
floods storms change resource
variability to the point we don't
understand it rising sea levels impact
and freshwater shrinking snow cover you
know it never occurred to me that when
you look at like the Rocky Mountains
that's water storage what happens if it
is the storage is in there that means a
lot to the west because if you don't
have dams to store it it runs off
quicker than you can use it so it's just
interesting river level river levels
flows temperatures already talked about
what that could mean to the disruption
of power generation and water shortages
in cities could restrict our ability to
heat cool and electrify buildings so
what if this is all true right I was out
of the conference in California a couple
weeks ago and on the wall street journal
does it every year it's called economics
so George Shultz was up there speaking
okay so you know the Secretary of
everything yes he was
it was labor he was state and defense
right i think was defense anyway he's
got to be in his 90s still sharp as a
tack but he brought up an interesting
example he went back to the reagan days
and it was about CFCs okay we thought
the ozone of the ozone layer that whole
thing some of you guys remember at some
others you don't so there was a lot of
science that said the ozone layer is
going to be gone we're all going to be
cooked we're all going to get skin
cancer crop failure blah blah blah lots
of science on both sides and so Schultz
describe this conversation that they had
and Reagan was sitting there listening
to his side of the aisle a bunch of guys
saying it's BS the science isn't there
we're not doing it he said you know what
it is that it is their slightest
possibility that it might be true camp
can we can see that it might be true and
so grudgingly you know some of the heads
and he said well why do we just buy an
insurance policy why wouldn't we buy an
insurance policy if it could happen what
I thought about was compelling about
that is many times we have these
discussions particular when you open
these discussions up to the broader
public we talk about carbon capture a
sequestration cap-and-trade nobody gets
it only experts get it and then then
maybe maybe they get it but when you
talk about an insurance policy doesn't
everybody get that me do we all buy
insurance yep to do what to protect
ourselves and our kids for what for the
obvious that's going to happen is my
house going to burn down oh my god it
you know am I going to die of a heart
attack tomorrow maybe not but I might I
just I thought it was a compelling idea
the idea of insurance and that you know
as we as we also try to take whatever
policies to the people because it's so
politicized some simple thoughts like
that we're talking about insurance here
you know if you had to tell everybody in
the US that they had to pay 500 bucks a
year to potentially protect their
grandchildren from the type of
calamities we're talking about they
might say okay I get it it's insurance
maybe not but I just thought it was an
interesting point he brought up so now
that I've thoroughly depressed you
by helen is grim seemingly grim future
I'm pleased to inform you as you all
know these practical solutions out there
there will be new technologies there
will be new policies I'm not going to go
through them you know what they are
there's tons of studies out there on
earth so I want to just close with a
focus on one thing focus on consumers
because I think we've become
over-reliant and don't take this the
wrong way because I know a lot of you
guys are working on technology but we've
become a bit over a line on the on the
technology side and the government
policy side you know government will
save is still figure it out that come up
with the radiances technology will save
us but you know what about us using less
and being really serious about that so
we start with a few questions why can I
check my stocks my bank account to the
penny my Facebook friends or unfriends
as it may be my linkedin request of old
friends looking for jobs the weather on
and on blah blah blah right on my
smartphone anytime I want yet I can't
tell if my kid left my plasma TV on I
can't tell if I forgot to turn the heat
down to 58 when I left even if I did or
did not why is that it's coming but why
is it taking so long okay why is it that
the only people who have that data right
now the ones selling you that stuff okay
so you know again my car can tell me my
instantaneous my marginal fuel use right
as i go up and down on the gas meter i
go in and out of cruise control I can't
tell how much i have no idea inside my
house nor does the utility because all
they have is one meter at the house or
the office tower of the factory you
can't tell what's going on a CFO again
can track the every penny the flows of
money are well tracked the flows of
kilowatt hours or gallons you can't tell
we've got to get there faster in a leave
you with another thought some of the
younger folks at my table which was
taken as a compliment you know grew up
in a data-rich world they're comfortable
with data they love data the data
junkies right give them data behaviors
will change i had this quick discussion
with my boy i was thinking about this i
said
so here's the deal what if on your phone
you could see how much all the
electricity and house we were using and
the water we were using and if it went
down I gave you a ten percent cut he
said when can i get it i mean we could
turn these into little wesco warriors
you know i'll do these data driven kids
in a minute i'm telling you you get them
the technology given the data they do it
and that's what the kid can do imagine
what a society could do that kind of
data so i think really you know what is
it we haven't unleashed the awesome
power of the information technology
revolution on these most fundamental
areas of societal challenge we just have
not we focused it on things like
Facebook things like LinkedIn that has
got to that has got to change now what
is coming I mean these new companies out
there I mean couple of our it's out
there will you'll be able to check on
your smartphone and you'll be able to
see what your house is doing challenges
I was just talking with a guy from 0
power it's great but you know he's just
reading the utility meter first thing
any don't you don't have any granularity
you know it's one thing to know what
your house uses how much does that help
you don't you want to know the
difference between what my fridge uses
my boiler uses my plasma TV uses the
hair dryers that should all be crushed
and burned you know I mean we need to
know that kind of stuff and it's not
that higher the technology exists so
then moving on to my to my next my final
set of questions so I talked about my
[ __ ] can tell me how much I'm using for
gas also when I go to buy my car I get
an MPG sticker right energy business did
this pretty world energy star ratings
right i can buy in any my furnace I can
get Energy Star rating my dishwashers
and Energy Star rating nothing out there
for water use right you have no idea how
much a product you buy uses for water
take a guess how many gallons of water
your pair of jeans is worth any idea
throw someone throw out of gas three
thousand
okay because you gotta grow the crop
harvest the crop make the gene and then
wash it a whole bunch of times and that
doesn't count the fact that you wash it
with hot water which is really probably
don't need to you compare that to you
know a pound of beef that's about 50
gallons you know again got to grow the
feed irrigate the feed to grow the feed
to feed the cow then you get a feed blah
blah blah blah but we should have these
type of labels you should know from an
energy and water perspective as a
consumer what the hell am I getting what
am i buying why is it I talked about why
is it that you know by the way ticket to
another level when I buy at office tower
or a home or a factory kind of big
investments when you like to know
particularly you know as you guys are
probably aware of many cities are
pursuing these labels on real estate
right now okay so Bloomberg did it in
New York Philly is followed suit
Boston's about to jump in Seattle's go
in there where every building is going
to have an energy use sticker on it you
want to talk about scrambling going on
right now with the wreaths and an
individual property owners because if
you get late well they've got to get
labeled when you get labeled as a dog
you're in trouble information
transparency is going to change
behaviors we need to get there quicker
so water departments why are they under
staff right now if you look at in the
u.s. I think it was the US Geological
Service did a study on water leakage out
of domestic systems the amount of water
leaking out of our pipes in our domestic
water systems equals twenty percent of
the total demand so 20 forget about the
fact that once you get it into your
house and you squirt it out on the lawn
just to get it to your house we're
already wasted twenty percent of the
total use so why is that I talked about
why can a CFO track every penny why is
it that most people in this room don't
have motion activated lights in their
house why haven't they converted to LEDs
why don't you have automatic timers on
your showers why are you washing your
clothes with hot
you know you know why because basically
we're blind as consumers we're running
blind on water and energy you know
climate just becomes an act exacerbate
er but we are running blind and as you
guys think about technologies think
about the mitigation side but please
think about the consumer side okay
figure out ways to get this information
in people's hands because they will they
will act out of self-interest they'll
act out of company interest they may
even act out a national interest at some
point because if we don't then what's
left if you don't act out of those then
what do you act out of crisis it's it
right it's not a foregone conclusion
that we're going to have dislocation
starvation wars over all of this it's
not a foregone conclusion that's how
many things have changed in the past
right so it's it's not a done deal that
that isn't going to happen but the point
is particularly on this consumer side
when you look at the bite we can take
out of demand just by having smarter
consumers and really caring about
conservation and I think the caring will
come with the transparency I really do
maybe I'm a you know maybe it's
Pollyanna but I don't think so so anyway
we need more [ __ ] wats and more
negative I'm going to use that one
alright thanks for your time and
attention and oh by the way you have
till tomorrow at the end of business to
solve all this stuff
and now i think i'm going to have a
glass of wine